[MUSIC PLAYING]
So now that we've written the
code to sign the user in,
let's go through the process
of adding a sign-in button.
And maybe before we do that, we
should ask ourselves, why
are we even adding
a sign-in button?
After all, Game Center kind of
does what we did, right?
It signs the user in
as soon as your
application is started.
So what does Google Play
need to be different?
And the answer is that Play
Games and Game Center are
slightly different animals.
With Game Center, we can have
a number of different
applications that all use,
essentially, the same Game
Center service.
And what that means is, when the
first game the user ever
attempts to play on this
device signs in to Game
Center, the user will see an
approval dialogue, and maybe
they'll have to go through
a few setup steps.
But then for every other
application, when they attempt
to sign the user into Game
Center, that request will be
approved or denied
automatically.
There's no additional dialogues
that the user needs
to see at that point.
So it's generally considered OK
behavior to try to sign the
user in right away.
Generally speaking, it's really
only that one first
game where the user's going to
see any kind of dialogue.
On the other hand, with Play
Games, you essentially have a
separate service associated
with each application.
And permission to access this
service is on an application
by application basis.
That means that the user may
go through an approval
dialogue to, say, sign in to
Play Games on one game.
But then they'll still need go
through an approval dialogue
for every other game that wants
to use its own version
of Play Game services.
And the user can accept or
reject each of these
applications as he
or she sees fit.
And on top of that, these
generally aren't in-game
approval dialogues.
We have to switch to an
entirely different
application, usually Google+ or
Mobile Safari, to show that
OAuth sign-in dialogue.
So it can be a jarring
experience to start up that
game and immediately having to
switch to an OAuth screen
without giving the user any kind
of context as to what's
going on or why they're
switching to another
application.
And that's why we want to be
careful about signing the user
in to play games as soon as
they start up your game.
We want to avoid this
experience.
So how do we present the sign-in
button to the player?
Well, my recommendation is be
assertive yet friendly, much
like this puppy.
Hi, buddy.
And what I mean by that is, yes,
you don't want to switch
the user to an OAuth consent
screen as soon as they start
up your game.
But on the other hand, neither
do you want to hide the
sign-in mechanism through some
hidden menu feature.
I've seen applications that have
social login features.
But they're often hidden
behind a menu.
I've got to go into Options or
Features and Preferences, and
somewhere in there is
my social login.
And you might think it first
that maybe you want to put
your Google+ sign-in
there as well.
However, you have to remember
that this sign-in process
enables a number of features
that aren't purely limited to,
say, sharing something on
your social network.
Play Games can also, for
instance, store your scores on
leaderboards or save your game
in the cloud or record
achievement progress.
And if a user's in a situation
where they think they've
submitted their score to a
leaderboard, and then it turns
out that that leaderboard
never got their score
submission in the first place
because they weren't signed
in, the user could be
genuinely unhappy.
Same deal if they thought
they were earning a
difficult-to-earn achievement,
and then they don't get credit
for it because they
weren't signed in.
Or even worse, they think
they're saving their game to
the cloud, and they're not,
because they forgot to sign in
on this device.
So I do recommend being a little
more aggressive with
your sign-in button
than hiding it
away in a menu somewhere.
Two patterns that we've seen
that have generally been
fairly successful are one, put
your sign-in button somewhere
fairly prominent on, say, your
title screen, where the user
will first see it.
Maybe even include a little text
that says, hey, sign in
here to save your scores to
social leaderboards, or
something like that.
A second pattern we started
seeing is games asking the
user, through an in-game
dialogue box, when they first
start up the game, if they
would like to sign in to
Google to enable Cloud Save.
I suppose this method is a
little more assertive than the
previous method, so our puppy
is slightly more assertive.
But this is a pattern worth
looking into, particularly if
you're game uses Cloud Save.
This is a case where if the user
isn't signed in, and they
think they're saving their game
to the cloud and they're
not, they could be
really unhappy.
So in that case, it might be
worth being a little more
assertive about promoting
sign-in.
Again, stay polite
but assertive.
So with that in mind, we can
finally go back to adding our
sign-in button to our game.
Now I'm going to switch to my
nib here, and I'm going to add
two things.
First, I'm going
to add a label.
And let's put it here, and
it'll stretch out a bit.
We'll have it display a nice
little message that says,
"Sign in for Achievements and
Leaderboards." And I'll go up
here and make it right aligned,
change the number of
lines to 0, and maybe we can
fix the word-wrapping.
There we go.
And then we can resize this
thing a bit, so we can
drag it like this.
Sorry, this is kind of
painful to watch, but
we'll move it over.
All right.
I could spend the rest of this
video futzing with this thing,
but that's good enough.
The next thing we're going to do
is add our sign-in button.
Now, I'm going to show
you something.
I'm going to use the official
Google+ sign-in button.
And here's how I'm
going to do it.
First, I'm going to drag
this button on screen.
And then the next thing I'm
going to do is go back into my
Downloads Library.
And I'm going to open up
the Google+ iOS SDK.
And you remember how I
told you not to add
this Google+ bundle?
Well, for demo purposes,
I'm going to add it.
You can follow along if you
want, but we're going to
delete this all in
a few seconds.
So, up to you.
But I'm going to add this
Google+ bundle.
I'm not going to copy it,
just add as a reference.
And then this button, I'm going
to change its class from
a UI button to a GPP
sign-in button.
This stands for Google+ Platform
Sign-In button.
And then the last thing I'm
going to do is go into my
IntroViewController, and I'm
going to remove this call here
to authenticate within
viewDidLoad, right?
We don't want that to happen
automatically.
We want the user to click
the sign-in button.
I forgot one thing.
Let's go back to my Xcode
project, my nib.
And using my springs and struts,
let's change this so
that these all are anchored
to the bottom here.
That'll make sure that when
the screen get shortened,
which it will, because it's
within a navigation
controller, these buttons
and labels will
still be seen on screen.
And the last thing we're going
to do is actually remove all
the text from my button.
So it looks like an empty button
with no text, right?
But now watch what happens
when I run it.
That empty button with no text
magically has been turned into
a Google+ sign-in button.
Isn't that cool?
Not only that, but it follows
all of the proper branding
guidelines.
It turns out that making the
sign-in text slightly offset
from the center like
this is not easy.
And what's even cooler is that
if I were to view this in
French or German or one of a
number of other languages that
we support, this text would
be properly localized.
There's no additional work I
would need to do to localize
this thing.
And now watch what happens
when I click the button.
After a couple of moments, you
can see that authenticate was
called for me.
Again, I didn't have to add
any code for this to work.
This Google+ button made all
the calls for me, right?
It made a call to GPPSignIn
sharedInstance
authenticate for me.
I didn't have to do any other
code to hook it up, which is
pretty cool.
And so in case you're asking,
hey, Todd, if this Google+
sign-in button is so great,
how come you're not
actually using it?
The reason is that these
tutorials are generally made
for game developers.
And so I know that for many of
you, you prefer to render your
buttons inside your game
engine yourself.
It can be somewhat problematic,
I think, to take
a UI button or some class of a
UI button and somehow display
it on top of your game engine.
A lot of game engines just
don't work that way.
And so my point here really is
just to show you that this
Google+ sign-in button isn't
magical, but it does do three
things for you.
Number one, it properly displays
the sign-in button
using all the proper branding.
Number two, it localizes
the text for you.
And number three, it
calls authenticate
when you click it.
But since I don't want you have
to rely on the Google+
sign-in button, we're going to
get rid of this official
sign-in button and just do it
ourselves with the regular UI
button so that you can see the
code that would get called in
case you want to render this
button inside your game
object, which I imagine
many of you will.
So let's do that.
First thing to do is let's
delete this bundle, because
we're not going to use it.
Goodbye.
And then we're going to say that
this button is, in fact,
just a normal old UI button.
The next question you might be
asking then is, OK, great.
So how do I display this sign-in
button using all the
proper branding guidelines and
the offset text and all that?
And for me, the answer is
usually, let's just display
these as graphic buttons.
You don't get the advantage of
localizing your text, but it
is a little easier.
So if you go to this link that's
going to magically
appear on your screen right now,
I have a link to a zip
file that you can download that
contains some of the art
work that you would need to
display your own Google+
sign-in button.
Once you download the zip file,
you'll have something
that looks a little like this.
We can unzip it, and we've got
a folder named Artwork.
And let's just drag this
into our application.
And yeah, let's copy it.
And at this point, I'm just
going to take this UI button,
and I'm going to say it's
Type is Custom.
And let's start changing
the images.
So Normal for when you're signed
in normally, or we're
displaying the button
normally.
Change our State
to Highlighted.
And in that case, I'm going
to use the signin_pressed.
We'll use the same
one for Selected.
And then when you're Disabled,
I'm going to use
signin_disabled.
And so now our UI button is
still a UI button, but it has
a complete clean,
graphic look.
And so it kind of looks like the
official sign-in button.
The next thing I'm going to
do is let's a few of these
things, bring up our
Helper Editor.
And I'm going to just start
adding some outlets for my
button and my label.
Some I'm going to drag
this in here.
And it's an outlet, and I will
call it signinButton.
And I'm going to do another
one for the label.
And we'll be referencing these
later to hide the button or
change the text of the label,
depending on whether the
user's signed in or not.
And then finally, I'm going to
take my sign-in, and I'm going
to drag it in here and
create an action.
We will call it
signinButtonWasPressed.
And all I actually need to
do here is call GPPSignIn
sharedInstance authenticate.
Again, this is really all that
the official Google+ sign-in
button does when you
click on it.
So we needed to add in this
one action, but otherwise,
we're going to get a button that
behaves pretty similarly.
So now we can run this.
And I'm going to click
the sign-in button,
and there we go.
We have our bearer token here
in our console log.
So it looks like
sign in worked.
By the way, in case you're
wondering why we're not seeing
that OAuth dialogue that we
saw the first time, it's
because our system is smart
enough to know that if you're
logging in or signing in to
the same application as
before, with the same account as
before, and the application
isn't asking for any new scopes,
and you haven't done
anything to deauthorize the
application, it will assume
that you're still cool
with signing in.
And so it won't show that
sign-in dialogue every time
you want to sign in,
which would start
to get pretty tedious.
We can take advantage of the
situation by automatically
signing the user in on
subsequent visits.
So it kind of makes sense to
have this button on screen if
it's the first time the user has
visited the application,
or they haven't signed in.
But if user's already designed
in, and we know that we can
sign them in silently, well,
then at that point, it makes
sense to go ahead and do so.
And we can do that
by calling the
trySilentAuthentication method.
And we're going to do that
by going into my
IntroViewController, and
viewDidLoad after I initialize
GPPSignIn, I'm going to call
GPPSignIn shared instance
trySilentAuthentication.
Now, what this method does is it
basically looks and sees if
I've signed in in the past
with this application.
If I have, it'll just go ahead
and try and sign me in, no
clicking on the sign-in
button required.
So let's see what happens
now when I run it.
So we started up the
application.
I'm not going to click on
the sign-in button.
But it looks like I've
successfully authed anyway,
which is cool.
Now, there are clearly
some cleanup tasks
we need to do here.
We don't want this sign-in
button sticking around if the
user has already signed in.
We probably want to hide
it, or maybe change
it to sign-out button.
We probably want to change
the label once the
user is signed in.
And we'll be dealing with all
that in a future lesson.
But for right now, let's take
a closer look at this access
token and see what magical
powers this has granted us now
that the user has signed in.
And we'll be looking at that
in the next lesson.